face it's our primary means of
communication yeah but it's been
untapped in terms of a human-computer
interface how are you dr. Peter can
express itself to you in a human-like
way which is emotional that's cognitive
no that's when you start getting to this
sort of interesting place going to see
an AI baby on a sunny afternoon the
fellow you meet next is a madman in the
best possible way you gotta pull the
muscles which basically lower the brow
is mark Sager a computer scientist at
the University of Auckland so now he's
ranked Clem would be yeah anesthesia
noise Winkler and she's laser mark
became famous for building super
detailed simulations of the human body
and ended up winning a couple of Oscars
for his work on films like Avatar and
King Kong sorry stay here and these days
mark is how to put this trying to
reverse engineer the human brain he's
built a series of simulations around how
the human face moves how we express
emotion and how our neurons fire we're
trying to build a computer which has
experiences can imagine and basically it
has its own sort of existence in a way
so now what we're gonna do is I'm going
to run baby X
while we're building here's a computer
that can learn so this is baby she's
sort of looking at us and hearing us if
I make a loud noise they should get a
fright
this is what she can see so you can see
my face here hey Tina alright so she's
not copying my smile she's responding to
me and now this is her little fist
baby's fist weird but so you can pick a
bigger page and I show us something but
she has to be looking at it's a get her
attention
hi baby hi hi hi what do you see
what's this puppy very good what's that
baby
this is cuz we're in New Zealand you
gotta show your shape yeah I'll give her
the word yeah yeah hi baby
hi what do you see baby sheep very good
baby the long-term goals is can we
create a computational model of
consciousness because then you get go
okay the computer model has just become
conscious of something is that for from
now all the facial expressions
everything is driven by neural nets so
as we look around I'm going at those
nails remove her face basically and so
this is what's driving in the background
and so what you're looking at now these
are all the connections lighting up like
as the baby's doing stuff and this is
like a simulation of what would you have
running Russell's brain yeah because if
you're going to make a character
biological and behave naturally then
you've got to use a natural model so
this is sort of what's going on inside
baby s now we take this stuff and we are
now connected to cognitive computing
systems so you've got biological neural
networks connected to artificial
intelligence models and the potential
for that's enormous that's where the
future is probably going to be maybe
you